there are so many new Beauty releases
happening all the time so we gathered
some of the most hyped products to test
for ourselves we have yet another color
changing product to review this is the
Kylie Cosmetics transformative liquid
lip tint that was a part of her collab
with the Wizard of Oz it goes from
emerald green to Pink the smell is
interesting it kind of smells like an
Appley shampoo the formula is pretty
thin I do like this giant doe foot
applicator the color is actually a
little more unique than other color
changing lip products I've tried the
pink was a bit deeper and I think more
flattering on my skin tone I would wear
this again because the stain it leaves
behind is pretty but I do wish the
formula was thicker these are the flaky
Friday Cosmetics Crystal crease
eyeliners these are handmade reusable
Crystal eyeliners that you apply with
lash glue it was a little hard for me to
get them in a comfortable spot because I
have hooded Lids you can cut these to
fit your eye shape better so I'm gonna
do that next time but I think these are
so fun they look like you just did so
much work applying each individual
rhinestone circulars is one of my
favorite nail polish brands and they
just drop their holiday collection I
love that they have a spin on the
classic red and green this mix of pearly
Shades and then this more unique
duochrome sachet reminds me of red bows
and Christmas ornaments to me it leans
more pink than red but it's still
beautiful verdigri jelly is a jelly
polish it is more sheer because it's a
jelly so I did three layers and it
looked so shiny my favorite shade in the
collection is definitely Tahitian Pearl
which is this dark duochrome that shifts
from pink to green and it has this
holographic glitter in it I did three
coats for this one too because it showed
the color shift better and I think it
made the glitter pop more this is a
really unique color and I can see myself
wearing it a lot the last three shades
are all a pearlescent sheer white with
different colored shimmers Serenity has
a green Shimmer so lay has a pinky red
Shimmer and siren has a purple Shimmer
these are all really pretty but you
definitely don't need all of them
because they're so similar this entire
fire collection applied really smoothly
and even though some shades had to be
layered up I was happy with how they all
turned out this is the half magic magic
flick liquid eyeliner it has this really
interesting tip that's paddle shaped so
you can draw fine lines with the edge
and then fill in with the wide side I
suck at eyeliner but this shape actually
really helps me draw the wing easily I
will say that I think the actual
eyeliner formula is not the best the
black isn't super pigmented like I would
prefer but I really liked this tip shape
this is the KVD Dazzle long wear
eyeshadow stick it's supposed to be a
one and done type product so you don't
need primer you just swipe it on and
blend I was really surprised at how soft
this formula is it's actually a little
too soft like you have to be gentle with
it but it really does glide on easily
this is packed with glitter and Shimmer
and it just looks so pretty on the eyes
it's like a way to do glitter without
any of the mess I'm a fan I tried a
couple products from the K Beauty brand
romand this glitter palette has been
raved about so I was really excited to
play with it the shades are meant to be
on the softer more translucent side so
you can layer them over eyeshadow I just
applied some of my blush on the eyes and
then applied a few of the shades on top
there are Shimmer formulas fine Glitters
and more chunky Glitters overall I would
say the formulas are on the dry side but
they were actually pretty easy to work
with I had no problem swiping or patting
them on and I had little to no Glitter
fall out I also tried the glasting water
tint the color and gloss are separate
layers so you get that long lasting tint
with a glossy finish these feel so
hydrating and comfortable on the lips
they're really lightweight and they
definitely do leave a stain look at my
hand after I wipe those swatches off
foreign
[Music]